remove that parentheses because that was just more a note for me. These are like lower risk
opportunities that allow students to test their ideas and make predictions and the outcome hopefully
from this is students start to pursue a deeper understanding voluntarily so we're pushing them
more towards that intrinsic of motivation type and yeah this teaching philosophy is going to
guide many other things I'll discuss today. Now on to Chem 110. When we think about the student base
for Chem 110 students enter with very different futures some will continue to 112 and 210,
some will continue to 112 and then into their major specific courses and some will just finish
after 110 and into their major specific courses. Not saying that. So each path is going to have
different priorities and each student's value and each student is going to value different outcomes
from this course and because of this the course has to provide value to every student and not
just a subset of students and when we're coordinating a large multi-section course
we're not debating what content to remove but deciding what every student must gain regardless
of their next step in academia or fields. Now these decisions are going to define the core goals
for the course and guide how we structure our content our assessments and support.
No none of the majors that's why they're not listed here. I'm saying that it doesn't matter
what their major is it matters that we have to understand there's a lot of different majors
that we're dealing with so when we build something it has to serve everyone.
I'm about to get to it. Now where was I? So here when we establish our learning goals I think we
have to establish them on different levels so there's sometimes departmental levels or student
levels or even university levels but starting off we can have meaningful understanding where this is
more of a student-centered goal where we're connecting chemistry topics to things that they
actually care about. Then we have one that kind of mixes a departmental level type of goal with
student-centered goals and this is the transferable skills you get from chemistry and lastly it's more
of this chemistry perspective on why we teach chemistry and that's the scientific literacy.
Now from this course goals are more than just statements on our syllabi they provide the
framework for everything our students are going to do in this course so that means when we have
learning objectives they need to map back onto our course goals so take for instance the talk I gave
earlier was about IMFs and the first two goals or objectives that I discussed really align with
this scientific thinking part of our goals but the last objective discuss falls into both this
meaningful understanding and scientific thinking and by making this line alignment explicit we
ensure all sections of the course reinforce the same priorities and that students are consistently
building skills and understanding that they and the department value and we'll take this even a
step further that from our learning objectives we map back to goals and from our assessments we line
align back to learning objectives so everything is mapped in this backwards design-like approach.
Now moving on now that we have the basis for how we build a course we have to think about the
current Chem 110 sequence and it's internally coherent from a chemist perspective it follows
the logic the logical organization of the discipline but experts and offices don't build
information the same way so what makes sense to us often doesn't make sense to a student
encountering these ideas for the first or second time. Instructional order then should align with
how understanding actually forms in which students need to construct their own knowledge so when we
take a look at everything that we could possibly cover in a chemistry course there's a lot and
there's a few different places we can start and rather than doing this atoms versus or atoms first
versus reactions first it might better help our students if we do it by guided questions throughout
the course. Not using this explicit layout but something similar to it we can now look at
everything that we teach in Chem 110 there's a lot of topics and simply by establishing a
guided question setup we can set up five units where we start off with why are materials different
something that students can easily comprehend because they understand there's a difference
between objects we can then narrow this down to what determines what an atom is from there we can
discuss how atoms build substances why do substances mix separate and react and lastly
I'll change that to how does energy change during chemical processing use so you know
is there a question no okay so unit one is really discussing why a material is different and the
logic behind this was I believe it is fair to say any student coming in understands there is a
difference between ice drinking water or liquid water and steam so this is a very qualitative place
to start where we can talk to students about something that they understand and can immediately
connect with we then narrow it down into particles and understanding how we build things
do you think you run the risk of like starting so easy that people think it's going to be a cakewalk
I don't think so because we also get into these phase diagrams and heating curves early on so
it's kind of like insight into what we'll do later like here we're going to come back to these
diagrams and actually do math but they'll kind of get like a little bit of back and forth
but yeah then we'll move into what determines what an atom is and this is getting more into
this like theoretical and conceptual stuff that students can't see we'll move into how we build
substances so all the bonding about it and lastly or not lastly then we'll go into like reactions
and how we form things and finally we'll end with energy and the point of ending with energy is
most students leaving chem 110 will need this concept of energy no matter what course they're
going into whether it be chem 110 or their major specific courses energy isn't going away all right
so I spent some time yeah what do you think energy will kind of drop hints about it throughout but I
think energy while students understand that it exists it's hard for them to conceptualize early on
so I've talked a lot about how we design a course around how students learn chemistry
but now we should actually talk about the students in this course and understanding that a well-designed
course is necessary but not sufficient for students to succeed in chemistry and if we look across many
universities chemistry is consistently one of the highest courses with or one of the highest
dfw rates among courses and they're wrong with that yeah we want students to succeed
we just teach hard things and not everybody can do it I don't think it's about teaching hard things
I think we haven't adapted the teaching model well enough since what like the 1980s or 70s
where it was like very industrialized so the goal zero the goal isn't zero but it is to decrease it
for what I think what they usually want like a specific like abc rate versus the df rate so
I don't know what that rate is currently but I would say like on a Gaussian curve we probably want
the like the tail end to stay the same but not get it down to zero but not have it up to 23 percent
and yeah as we look at the big 10 which Penn State is a part of we see a very similar pattern with
the dfw rate and these outcomes reflect a multifaceted issue that persists due to numerous
factors such as course structure student faculty relationships study strategies chemistry content
and personal factors outside the classroom and to a certain extent we've already designed or
discussed course structure but I also want to acknowledge personal factors or personal
circumstances right now as these can affect students and due to the complexity and sensitivity
of these factors I won't discuss them but I do understand that they are prominent reasons for
dfw occurrences instead the next section is really going to focus on factors a course coordinator can
meaningfully influence and how students engage with the course content and how the instructional
team supports them so moving on to student faculty relationships students struggle with chemistry and
I think a big part of this is coming from us under I can't talk is coming from us
misidentifying their not misidentifying not identifying their confusion early enough so
my goal here is to make struggle visible early so intervention is possible and I find one of the
barriers to this isn't logistics of how many students we have but it's the social risk of
being in a large lecture classroom what like before exams halfway through the first lecture
before an exam happens so students often understand less than they appear to but they
don't reveal that confusion in an environment where participation is going to feel costly and I
think we can address this in three different ways and the first one is lowering lowering the
interpersonal barrier to asking questions so students have to feel able that they can approach
the instructor and part of the way that we can facilitate this is by learning our students names
greeting them having conversations with them are you going to have all 12 of the faculty members
you're working with summarize the 385 people that work not 385 but if you're constantly interacting
with students you should start to learn at least some of their names I think the 300 students is a
bit intense especially if you're teaching two sections like that's nearly impossible
talk to them like say hello have conversation I mean I think it's partly just like you have to
you're you're a professor right you could you could but that in the I guess like reviews of
your teaching I think like from like peer to peer rather than student reviews it's something that I
would know because it is important to build that report yeah I mean it might be important I agree
but so is writing a paper I mean it's more just like just interact with your students right like
oh I understand that but selling it to the people that don't want to do it yeah yeah I mean it's
going to help your students in the long run and I think that should be the motivating factor here
like part of your job is teaching and we have to acknowledge that like it's easier to learn
from someone that you have a relationship with than it is to just sit in lecture and stare at a board
what if you think around to the people that you teach with we will be your colleagues and just ask
them who they talked to this week and whether they learned anything interesting about the students
okay right yeah like they get the message that you're curious to know like I'm gonna yell at them
yeah um people don't like being asked yeah I know um second we have to build a participating
participatory learning environment so this means when we're asking questions or working with our
students we have to give enough wait time we have to validate for partial answers and have them
explain their reasoning and this makes discussion expected rather than risky it also allows us to
begin to evaluate understanding before an exam and in class and lastly it's multiple pathways
to ask questions and this is more just facing the reality that some students will never ask the
question in lecture and it's not because they don't have any questions but there is a big social cost
to raising your hand in a classroom up two to three hundred students so giving them anonymous
or informal question pathways allows them to engage without that social cost or risk
like what are the first one to add that way no no but I had wow I guess first I won important
thing but like what pathways I think like the easiest one there's already a paper on it is
like using google forums where there's just a constant like form open and when they looked at
the research for it it was like less than like 10 percent were not using it correctly and not
using it correctly they were just like writing hi what's your favorite animal and even then like I
I think that's fine because that does build rapport are we not talking about asking questions
no we are but I think it's more about like giving them the opportunity not to have to ask it during
class because there is a social risk so giving them like a google form they might fill it out
during class and I might not answer it during class because that requires me to go into that
but then I can post it on canvas or whatever site that we feel like using I mean it would just be
like a thing on the canvas page like have a question go here no I would I would be the one
moderating it I think it is doable and I think people do not underestimate how much work I'm
willing to put into something I mean assuming most of them are chemistry questions I'm either
going to guide them to where the answer is or answer it and then post it on like a discussion
board on canvas like put it somewhere where everyone can access it or maybe the e-books
probably better for that yeah the e-books probably better for that do you consider getting help with
l.a.'s I mean we could do l.a.'s and ta's also like the idea is I'm not asking the instructors to do
it like I will handle the logistics of responding to these question forms and yeah l.a.'s and ta's
I mean let's imagine one percent of the class ask questions every day yeah you now have 30 questions
to ask or in detail I mean some of them might be easy yeah that's oh yeah using l.a.'s and ta's and
the other support systems that we have so in undergrad my professors would do this thing where
that they wanted us to answer about ourselves and then we would ask them a question they didn't have
to be chemist related to be about themselves but then on Fridays they would like pull the questions
out of the hat and metaphorically and then answer some chemistry ones and then some personal ones
and I really liked it I felt like it did a good job of balancing like here's my my actual topic
problems that I have and then here's me getting to know you and that way you don't have to answer
3,000 questions you know maybe you and the answer everybody well I guess chance to push themselves
to ask something it might be nice if we see like a constant question popping up to address that
like send it out to people so just keeping an eye on like how many times this question was asked
because I do still want to give each student the opportunity to you know yeah it'd be pretty easy
to summarize that with all the questions that are being asked yeah and you can have people I mean
the teens and l.a.'s that already run the like resource rooms kind of like that I guess one
question I would ask is like are you running are you running the risk of not having people come to
the resource room I think students will use this when like we already have limited people coming
to the resource room right like they're only coming there before an exam or what homeworks do
so we're really trying to get the students who already don't come to the resource room
to like give them like now your face is not attached to this
that's the eventual goal with the firebase app that I'm trying to make but I don't know if that's
the like time to talk about it but like if someone asks me the question I can go into like the details
about like I'm trying to make an app that handles that in real time but I have other priorities at
this current moment I mean I think part of the thing is they're getting an expert from the people
who run the course so like the people who are designing the exams so you can go to the internet
but as students have learned that sometimes chat gbt is wrong sometimes check is wrong and if they're
using google and they're using the ai overview that google gives they're also going to run into
that situation where sometimes it's wrong here it's the same cost you're just going to a google
form instead of going to google.com or chat gbt so I don't think it's a high cost to get students to
do it because it's really about the same amount of clicks that it would be for any other
next on to study strategies and how a student approaches their engagement with material
this often can impact how likely they are to succeed so here I'm really going to just focus
on recitation in which I want to develop recitations that foster reasoning and support
student success and if we look at multi-year studies and how supplementary instruction
impacted DFW rates there appears to be inconclusive evidence of specific of a specific addition
directly coinciding with the decrease in these rates while across the years there is a general
decrease there are many factors that could be the cause of this especially when we consider the
evolution of technology across this multi-year study. This is chemistry however this yeah one
particular place however this does not mean that the addition of supplementary instruction is futile
take for instance when we're looking at recitation yeah it kind of hops back and forth but this
doesn't automatically improve learning and the reason is that recitation can serve a variety of
different purposes it could be a second lecture a worksheet session or a space where students
actively reason through chemistry problems it seems like there's a meaningful decrease after
the modular and flipped classroom approach but it still kind of hops back and forth and I think
that's kind of like is it just because of this or is it because like all of these things now
well that was so like there is a general decrease but we're also looking in 2014 which is most
likely when most people had personal computers at their access at least college students did.
So here I propose rather than changing recitations altogether just adapting our
current recitation activities to model this process oriented guided inquiry learning
and early implementations of Pogel and general chemistry did show lower DFW rates and I don't
present this as definitive evidence but because student outcomes are going to vary across semester
and institution instead it suggests that how recitations are structured may matter more than
the existence of recitation itself. So here Pogel activities that should have popped in next
Pogel activities are going to follow a what just happened a consistent progression where students
explore data or observations they're then able to develop the concepts from that exploration
and finally apply that to new situations. So going back to IMFs because I love them
an idea for how we would do this is we would give them structures and boiling points we would ask
them to then explore by identifying the IMFs and identifying any trends they see with just boiling
points then we want them to connect these two concepts by comparing the IMFs and trends and
then apply this to new molecules and start predicting relative IMFs and strengths or boiling points.
And considering my first 4k award was about designing recitations I feel very
good with the workflow of designing worksheets and implementing these changes. Now lastly I'm
going to group up two categories together and that's because here I want to focus on how we
approach assessments and this section is going to shift from how students learn to how we assess
what they have learned and my argument here isn't that exams are too hard or that we should make
them easier instead I think the issue with the current format is we don't want to be able to
measure the answers we don't always measure understanding very well so current exams are
using this binary system where a student is either correct or incorrect but student understanding
exists on a continuum and in a multiple choice exam we don't get to see where their understanding
lies a small mistake results in an incorrect answer. So our current exams aren't telling us
that they're not being asked to be confused. And of course research has spent a lot of time,
I know that's broken, trying to explore what a good medium is between multiple choice and free
response where people have done stuff like creative exercises which are like list everything you know
about this thing and yes there has been a decrease in the DF rates but creative exercises are also a
monster to grade because we're telling students to list whatever they know. There's also been
other research done on dichotomous versus politimous grading where say the answer choice is A but a
common mistake would lead you to answer choice B answer choice B would get 50 credit. Now I'm not
proposing we're doing something like this but rather looking at this middle range where what we
see is there is a large spread for the politimous grades for every one dichotomous grade. So what
we're really seeing here is that it's affecting students near this pass fail boundary by
distinguishing partial understanding from no understanding. I think it depends because we
never advertise that there is a curve. I think it just depends on however close we are to an A or
like 100 percent that's usually how I would curve a class. Tests aren't curves. I mean I might but
currently structure doesn't help. I have tried to convince them to do that and yeah it's hard to do.
Yeah so it also it doesn't really matter. I mean which is actually in my opinion argument for doing
it but it's used as an argument against doing it. I will build some goodwill then.
Yeah so my approach is trying to find something in between these two schemes that does give us
the opportunity to truly evaluate our students understanding and here I think yeah so it's kind
of dumb the way they did it. So essentially the like center dot that you can't really see because
they didn't color it is like the dichotomous grade that they would have gotten and then the spread
from that center dot on each like vertical is how much the grade could be affected with politimous
or maybe it's the bottom dot maybe that's a better one. Yeah I think it's the bottom dot
and then the politimous because you'll only get more partial credit. You'll get less. So like
bottom dots are dichotomous scores all the other dots in the same like line as a bottom dot is the
politimous spread. How would you talk about I will get back that that is the next slide.
All right so with this the way that I propose changing our exams to fit it is say we have an
exam level question that's multi-steps. Now our current exams are 30 multiple choice questions.
We should reduce that to 20 and then choose three questions that are multi-parts to start grading
and the way this works is if you have a correct answer on your Scantron or answer sheet you get
full credit and if you don't you get graded for partial credit and this allows us to actually
understand a student's or to grade a student's understanding rather than just group them up
into correct or incorrect. Now using the current what oh no it's specific yeah yeah um moving on
to the current like this question and how we could do this say our exam looks like this in
grade scope it will look like this where we tell it where students would write the answer.
It can then do automatic grouping of the answers based off what a student writes.
So anyone that has the correct answer gets placed in group one. All other answers are
going to get placed in an ungrouped and that's because if it's ungrouped we have to grade those
individually or manually and if it's grouped all of them get graded at the exact same time.
Do you think there's like uh this is not really a real question for you but do you think there's
somebody studying there's got to be a student somewhere studying like how can I write an A
so that it looks a lot like a B as well? Yeah I mean it's like have you seen like the true and
false where they were like write a T and like it's also looking like an F so I mean yes we're
going to tell them the instructions would be like write in capitals write like as clear as you can
right and I'm just curious yeah well because you're you're going to count anything that's
marked as yes yes I mean we'll manually check it. I don't know you don't have to I think this is not
a critique I'm wondering how much people would thought on the look I would I would be like trying
oh yeah but if it can't like identify it well enough it will go into this ungrouped
and I also would manually go through it anyways.
I mean I would do it based off what work they showed yeah so like they wouldn't get grouped up
with the correct group they'd get in the ungrouped category and then I pause the timer for this.
Yeah if I get a job here you have to get into stupid
well you won't be taking chem 110 at that time.
It's like choose five students from the class and be like this is your job yeah do it don't worry.
I'll make sure your grade is fine at the end I am her boss.
Okay but continuing then everything that's grouped in the correct group gets graded
automatically we select it's correct and all submissions are graded everything that's ungrouped
we go through manually and choose on the rubric now of course who's going to do all this grading
and part of this is looking at our TA's time commitments and before proposing this structure
I did break down what our TA's were doing to get a idea of how much time we could use and currently
we are over the limit if we include everything that our TA's are supposed to do over eight over
a hundred and fifty yes eight over eight hours over the entire limit for the semester.
I instead propose shifting some of the responsibilities this gives us three hours
for grading for each exam it still gives us left over time and the biggest thing here is changing
how lecture is structured for our TA's. Now from this you might be wondering how are they only
attending 18 lectures well we have six TA's per instructor and here we have three days of class
so we're splitting up what days a TA is in class and not too worried about the support here there's
also learning assistance in there but I know some people although I don't think Lisa's going to be
there because I think this yeah the main sorry I'll pause this. I would get rid of also the like
lines around the lines oh I see I see yeah great yeah let me let me fix that I can do that
maybe maybe I can do that oh oh let me write oh thank you let me write stop why
established last week this is the established routine where we all
putting on this napkin. You're the biggest sign. You're like all right uh sorry let me continue all right but
establishing a new routine helps our TA's plan their weeks accordingly gives our students
consistent support throughout the time plus we will still have enough people in the classroom to
help out our students. Do you have to worry about I mean it seems like one of the reasons you have
TA's come is to help facilitate things and another well so let's start there okay uh you
were saying you want to ask questions and have students work in groups and come back to you do
you think two TA's is sufficient? I think two TA's is sufficient to walk the room but we also have
about like eight to ten LA's in the room and you'll just have them come to every lecture?
They already do yeah and then uh another reason TA's would come besides that is that maybe they
need to know what the material is and this is a way to ensure they've done it. I mean yes but if
we take like an actual look at what our TA's are doing they're not coming to every lecture so this
is more just aligning things with how things are going um so I do agree with these points but if
we're not using our TA's sufficiently we might as well reflect that in their actual workload
and responsibilities. On the days where you have all that? Review days and then the first class so
the students can learn the TA's or who the TA's are or at least associate a face. Now I've spent
the past several minutes talking about grading logistics and how we cleared up time for TA's to
grade but grading isn't the purpose of a teaching assistantship. Graduate teaching assistantships
are training positions and course structure should support that training so here I kind of grouped it
up into four big categories that are teaching or that we should be supporting our teaching
assistants with. The first is learning facilitation so this gives TA's a space to practice guiding
reasoning rather than just giving an answer. There's also student mentorship and it's really
important in Gen Chem 1 because for many first-year students the TA's are the most approachable
scientists that they're going to meet so kind of building these soft mentorship skills while they're
teaching. Next is communication so TA's here learn to translate expert thinking into novice learning
or novice understanding and lastly we have professional development and this is more about
building transferable skills that accommodate for both students that want to go into academia
or industry. Like they are experts in chemistry they have their bachelor's degree already.
Now if we go back to what our graduate TA is expected to do throughout the semester they have
a lot of different responsibilities and given the current structure that I proposed we have freed up
about nine hours of their time and instead of giving them more responsibilities I think we
should embed professional development into their current responsibilities and if we take a look at
a poll from a recent TA seminar that Morgan Vincent ran we see that there's a few things
that the TA's voted on or said that they valued in their teaching assistantship and this is split
up into assessment, reflection, feedback, community, and transferable skills so using these things we
can actually build them in our current responsibilities and I'll only highlight three here for time's sake.
The first is with recitation we can have our TA's discuss slide design, break down problems for
or how they break down problems for students and how they make materials accessible. All this plays
into like learning, facilitation, communication, and professional development which is going to be
required in their research groups, industry teams, or any collaborations that they do.
There's also grading so this is an opportunity for our TA's to learn about mentorship and
evaluation so we have our TA's practice making rubrics, writing exam questions, or making partial
credit decisions. These activities are going to reinforce the learning facilitation and student
mentorship through this like student advocacy lens and this goes beyond building assessments
but rather learning how to evaluate students. And lastly focusing on this end of semester reflection
that I believe is a worthwhile assignment and provides our TA's an opportunity to reflect and
evaluate their experience which they'll most likely forget by the end of grad school but saving it
for the end of the semester still faces that issue of them having a recall type of problem
where they're not going to remember every single thing that happened that semester so instead
splitting this up into three to five guided reflections throughout the semester with guiding
questions to help them and this will help them build their communication and professional
development skills as they think about what they've done and what they've gained through TAing.
Now each modification is small but deliberate where it does give them some more things to do
but on a small time commitment scale and this will all be integrated into how we run our TA
weekly meetings but obviously we'll have to do some of the work outside of the meetings to prep.
Now in short the TA time I believe is spent on teaching and professional growth not just grading
assignments and monitoring students. I'm doing pretty good. It said 40 to 50 minutes right now
I'm at 34 and I didn't pause at all times and I'm certain I will forget to say some of the things
while I'm up there. I'll probably remove like one or two more things anyways that I think are
a bit not sure what. Well do what you want. All right so so far I've discussed the course from
the perspective of an instructor and a course designer but a coordinator's responsibility is
much broader and the course is not taught by a single person it's taught by an entire team.
So we move on to logistics and coordination. In a multi-section course students and TAs are
experiencing one course even though multiple instructors teach it and variation in teaching
style is valuable but variation in expectations can be confusing. So when sections are
structured differently TAs struggle to support their students and students receive mixed signals
about how to succeed. The goal of coordination then is a consistent framework. Instructors may
lecture run interactive classes use a hybrid model or flip the classroom and those choices
should remain the instructor's choice and decision. What is shared though are the instructor
instructional elements so our learning objectives our exams homework study resources lecture slides
and LMS. Do you envision then like basically uh are there like exams there's going to be a block
of material for an exam and you tell people do whatever you want. No. For that as long as by the
end of the exam you've covered this material. Oh I see what you mean so I mean they're already
teaching it the way they want and I think that's okay um but yes there are like we share these
things and we should be on the same page for like each unit each exam. It's not like quizzes
yeah quizzes I think like the other things are more up to the instructor themselves
but like the bigger notes like since homework's in the e-book the study resources are in the
e-book these are why they're listed under shared. Now here I really want to focus on two things
which are the lecture slides and the LMS. So for lecture materials the goal here is accessibility
and usability not enforcement so I am proposing a shared course repository organized by topic
folders. Now each folder is going to contain the lecture slide master copy and figures uh
the figures used to in the slides and all instructors will have access to these folders
and instructors can modify the materials as they see fit so they can use the slides as is modify
them or make their own. The goal here is to reduce preparation time for instructors allow
TAs to know what students are seeing and ensure students across sections have access to comparable
learning resources. Now on to the LMS a coordinated course has to operate reliably at scale and in
Chem 110 we have roughly six to ten instructors about 30 TAs and about 3 000 students so the at
this size the organization of the course is going to directly affect student success and the current
LMS structure is going to work or does work well from the instructor perspective as it
allows content to be posted efficiently and consistently while requiring minimal updating
but from a student perspective or from however how students navigate the course isn't the way
the same way how I can't talk how students navigate the course isn't the same way that
instructors build the course so the information here is grouped into one large table which often
is hard for a student to go through especially when they're already confused and like hesitant or
yeah I'm not confused and when students cannot quickly find assignments expectations or support
resources the barrier to engagement increases and at large scale navigation then becomes a part of
accessibility. In my proposed structure we use a modular approach where each chapter is going to
have its own module with all the lecture material needed there each exam will have its own dedicated
module listing the relevant chapters and study guidance and assignments are grouped into their
own modules so students can easily find where to submit things this increases accessibility for
every single person in the course while maintaining that replication for each instructor.
And lastly focusing on assessment infrastructure.
They can do whatever they want with that it's just there because they a lot of them use
pre-lecture quizzes but I I want to change pre-lecture quizzes but I'm not talking about that here.
And lastly moving on to assessment infrastructure I spent a lot of time talking about assessments
and taking this one step further. The assessments here are written by multiple instructors trying
to share the responsibility of building this exam and without a shared infrastructure exam
construction becomes difficult to sustain and difficult to evaluate for fairness.
Currently questions are shared through a collaborative document like Google Docs which
works for assembling exam but does not create a lasting assessment system. So here using the
resources we currently have I propose building a structured question bank aligned to our course
learning objectives. So the first sheet is just an instruction sheet that has all the learning
objectives and what to do. Each instructor then has their own sheet where they can put in questions
the figures that will be linked in a shared folder the chapter and learning objectives and they can
select the learning objective from a drop down menu and they can also decide if partial credit
is acceptable for this and the goal here is an accessible system that instructors will actually
use and because each question is then tied to a learning objective it becomes more than a grade
it becomes information about what our students are understanding. And even better is after we
upload the exams that we built from these questions to Gradescope we can map the learning objectives
there as well and once we get the grades in we immediately get statistics back on how students
are doing based off learning objective. Now there's a lot more to the logistics and coordination
for general chemistry and here I really focused on lecture materials course LMS and assessments
throughout my time here at Penn State I've helped out with exam scheduling with working with 110,
112 and 310 whether that be organizing the proctors or being the person running around from each room
to make sure everyone is doing their jobs. There's also TA coordination which I previously discussed
and training TAs which hasn't been discussed as much but being the person who helped train TAs I
have some experience but we'll still need to talk with people like how to figure out the full
logistics of the training of TAs and that schedule and lastly SDR accommodations and academic integrity
filings which I have received training on but similarly something that I've worked for
and follow the established protocols. All right last section we're almost done we talked about
all the logistics and coordination and now we get to move on to more of how we can modernize such a
course. Now throughout this talk I've brought up a lot of different tools and here I'm just kind
of summarizing how we can use them to modernize the course. So first are these ELO learning objective
learning objective mapping tools using the capabilities of Gradescope and making a simple
repository in excel we can automate grading and get our ELO statistics out
but we also can leverage PSU tools that we currently don't use such as CDER which allows
us to evaluate teaching behaviors especially considering the wide variety of how we approach
teaching the class it would be nice to see if these instructional instructional practices
connect to any of our student outcomes and lastly using my the skills I built in my PhD such as data
analysis I know how to work with large data sets and code so I can analyze course data and hopefully
find ways to implement changes based off this data reflecting three different goals here or
three different ideas here the first is collect and automate second is reflect and understand and
lastly is analyze and implement now also as technology evolves we have to understand that AI
isn't going away anytime soon and instead we have to learn how to integrate it through all aspects
of the curriculum so beginning with how students interact with AI I think it's important that we
have our students understand how AI goes through chemistry content and then have them critically
engage with the outputs and reflect the idea here is before every exam we would have students create
a concept map receive uh receive and critique oh I see what I'm not there receive and critique AI
feedback so I'll send their concept map into whatever chat about of their choosing critique
the feedback and then make a new concept map so the way it looks is they create a concept map they
upload it it gives some critique we give them guided questions they answer them so take for
instance which suggestions were incorrect or irrelevant this one says isotopes don't have the
same number of protons question mark don't know what it was trying to tell me here but isotopes
do have the same number of protons but anyways they go in they reflect they revise it and they'll
submit the whole thing now based off of the AI final report uh Penn State had in 2024 they did
say they wanted AI integrated across multiple layers of the course so the first one that I'll
focus on is assessments because we've kind of already talked about it without hinting at it
saying that it was AI the great scope how it does the grouping is through an AI assisted grouping
thing that I don't know how it works but it's AI assisted grouping the next is learning so this
is with the AI concept map assignment for our students and lastly is infrastructure so this is
my idea here is every week I would go in I'd give it a prompt tell it what chapters we're covering
what learning objectives what assignments and what recitation topics and have it give us a 200 to
300 summary that we can send to our students so we have these weekly course guides created with
whatever again whatever chat bot I'm feeling that we can post to canvas to help our students navigate
that week a little bit better and we go back to this idea that we can group and automate things
uh learning gets our students to reflect and revise and infrastructure gives us clear
clarify and support lastly we end with accessibility so uh for those who don't know
by the end of April 2026 we have to make sure all our materials are accessible canvas has a
built-in tool for this but the idea is accessibility standards need to be met in a month so I won't have
this job in a month but I will focus on some other ideas for accessibility primarily using
the universal design for learning um in the context of slide design here we're really going
to focus on engagement and representation as action and expression aren't that applicable
to static slides but here making sure all the slides that we're using in our classrooms are
accessible uh for our students so looking at two slides can anyone tell me which one's more
accessible which one's easier to read which one uh doesn't hurt your head yeah yeah so kind of
getting all our slides to look like this now of course I mean point out yeah like just grab it
like no this but yeah talk about like why do you think that is maybe ask some questions but really
I think it's a dangerous question to ask so maybe I won't ask it people feel dumb if they answer
okay I won't ask it I'll just go over I think it would be better to explain
instead like here are two slides that if you haven't thought about this in great detail you
might not be able to tell the difference quickly between like which one's better but then you can
explain I mean like it doesn't have to be long okay it could help people understand like oh this
one has like many different fonts and like you know um like a lot of like visual clutter and things
like this and then you know and this has been like studied it's not like you're making this up
but I think that's better because you are talking to people who have never had any formal training
okay um and so yeah just go over it a little more don't don't give them the option to choose just be
like this is why you're wrong yeah yeah yeah I think it's fair to say like probably many of us
have made it would be better to educate people okay to ask them to be got it be incorrect
maybe it would be good to say that the slide on the right was designed with the help of somebody
who would need a more clear slide okay because with accessibility I know a lot of people who have
disabilities the big thing with research there is that they need to be included
in these studies not as a test subject but as a designer okay but yeah so redesigning the slides
so the font is a good font it's a sans sans serif right it's not supposed to be serif
the guidelines on the web are for sans serif yeah okay so like I think I personally think it's
updated but that is the general guidance yeah so like moving away from like times new roman or
funny fonts like getting a clear readable font making sure our sizes are correct we're using
contrast and color correctly bolding things and attracting attention where we need attention
attracted so the idea here is April 2026 we should meet it at the end of fall 2026 I hope
to have all the slides redesigned and a workflow established for when we create new content for how
we go about making sure accessibility is met and by in spring 2027 is just ongoing
updates for accessibility now I've spent a lot of time talking and going over my ideas for
gen chem and at the end all these efforts are meant so we are not only focusing on our students
and helping them succeed but focusing on the entire instructional team and improving chemistry
as a whole for Penn State and catching up to the standards of everywhere else around us
maybe leading that you know end up leading that leading that change we're the leaders now
yes thank you for your kind attention here McAtez that was 46 minutes with some bad pausing
yeah of course I didn't make these I didn't make these I mean it's not the end of the world but
I tried to find one that was bolder but I couldn't so I was like I could
whoa Anthony I don't know okay I'll send I'll send you the thing I mean if it's an svg you
just go in there and add an outline oh really I don't save them as svgs but I can well because
sometimes when you know I'm judging you when you know let me talk when you put enough when you put
an svg in adobe illustrator it sometimes breaks so I just got into the habit of not saving them
as svgs because if I need to make it a bit like a different figure in illustrator oh well if it's
in illustrator sorry if it's a vector art anything you can just add like an outline because yeah I
think it's because I have like certain fonts and stuff like that it like tries to change things in
it I'm like no please stop but yeah I could send it to you is this enough am I I think it's a lot
better I I'm skeptical just the only thing would be with the ai looking at concept maps because as
a student who had to do concept maps for the first time in analytical I was asking it questions about
what I'm doing it started using like usually for concept maps we're told to use certain thinker
terms so we know what's been working around and they had us using terms that we didn't include
every single time that's the point it's because the I want them to understand that ai can be
wrong sometimes and not helpful so by giving it a concept map it's going to get things that
they're not going to agree with but that's why they have these guided reflection questions where
they could be like this was irrelevant like this didn't help wasn't the concept map to demonstrate
how your mental framework works yes you're saying if the ai go ahead and tweak it so they still have
to make the original concept map well they could have I mean they could but isn't it yeah yeah so
the idea here is they make it so they still go through that process but when they give it to ai
it's going to have a little bit trouble analyzing it so they can see like ai is good at some things
but not good at other things and they can like point out using these guided questions like it
just gave me nonsense and that's okay it also depends on how this doesn't feel like for me when
I do my concept map I use a whole blackboard yeah and that's okay like they could do it however they
want but again that that's part of the point where like it's meant to be like ai isn't going
to give you great things because this is something that you drew and there's many different ways you
can draw this and many different mediums you can draw it on yeah it was done very purposefully
I chose concept maps so yes so like yeah here it's more so they can like I'm not telling them to
correct ai because I think what they'll notice very quickly with a concept map is it will give
some good ideas because it can pull out like the words that you're using but it has a lot of trouble
with like the connecting lines and like understanding that flow so like for this one it was giving like
awful ideas about yeah like the isotopes like it just I was like I don't know what you're trying to
say but like it did say like maybe you should add more things about like what you mean when you say
atomic number like circling it on the thing or like showing an equation for something which I
think is still helpful so I was able to change up some things about it but like the other things
weren't as helpful I was thinking a lot about the same I started I think if you under an example
when ai could be useful and correct maybe you could tell students like go ask chatqptu
whenever chatbot they use finding sources that I can use to study this topic it's gotten so much
better at that it has gotten so much better I will say like it will actually like have like a link
source now on the side any general comments on it like does the structure make sense like you know
hop from topics feel yeah I think it's good I would be I might be more
um explicit there we go about what is you talking about like your general thoughts you talking about
things you would actually want to do things that are like what you think works and what you would
implement in your class versus like what you would be trying to get other people to do okay so yeah
yeah I got it I'm not sure that it's necessary I think it's all fine and if somebody's asking
asking questions you can always be like oh I'm thinking out right now I'm just talking about
like what I want to do got it okay um so I'm not sure it's needed but that that's like the only
thing for me was like when you and you could maybe even do this at the when you have that first slide
it's like here's the different opponents you know you could be like this is we're basically
moving from like a general framework for how I think about education to like how I would
try to implement this in my course so like what uh coordination across multiple sections look like
okay yeah but I don't know if that's needed I think it might be helpful though like when I'm
talking about like different things that I like want to implement it like be more explicit like
I will take care of this like with recitations I think I was pretty forthcoming like I will make
the worksheets I can do this like that is something I will handle and things also that like you would
do and you would help other people do but wouldn't you know need to you know what I mean okay yeah
because yeah like I don't want to like have them thinking like they have to do this that's why I
also do it with like the weekly guides like I will do it I will send it to everyone no one else needs
to worry about it I can handle 15 weeks of making these but if you were to would you consider doing
the google forms in a way where you use that as like maintenance no I want to do discord but I
actually looked at Penn State's technology and discord does not approve so I will not say it
will I do it if I get the job probably so sorry okay okay because it like it's not going to make
them use something bad so here we go but I figure like that's a better one because then I can have
like two different chat channels like uh professor answering questions or like uh team answering
but like kind of going through that as like a uh a simpler approach to this I think so
yeah like because I would be the one running it I mean that's what we we didn't have one explicitly
for 411 but that's how students like they didn't email me they just messaged me on discord I like
it I think it sounds cool like you can see all the games yeah well I think again I mean most
students have it by now which is why like it's not going to be mandatory it's like here's another
avenue you can ask questions when you join it like you'll have your name first but once you're in you
can change it to whatever you want like this just to make sure it's just my students in there but
like it's more just to like lower that barrier again but I'm not going to say that in the talk
because again it's not approved and Anthony any general comments or specific comments
wait hold on for a second I'm so sorry stop stop sorry um did we decide where we want to go later
uh no but I go into cinema art seminar in the 330s and I meet with Jackie and her under her
head uh and whenever that's done I'm free we can go anywhere we did not decide I think um I think
anti-fragile is a great place but we can try other places if we want more sophisticated
not till six oh we can migrate what are the other 6 45 it's so late
that's fine with me the anti-fragile whenever everyone's ready right sorry Anthony continue
you said slide eight like how do I sorry I'm trying to what did it it's listening to me
I my keyboard's back though that's why well it's like normalizing struggle but also identifying
when it's not like productive struggle I think there's like two two differences between these
things identify non-productive struggles okay so maybe when I bring it up later uh yeah or something
I mean yeah good maybe you don't have to but I have an answer for if someone does ask yeah of
course but sometimes you want to beat people into asking questions just like have a good
answer well that's why like some of the setup is built the way it is that's why I introduced like
the assessment grading before I talk about who's going to grade it because I know I know the next
question is how are we actually going to get this like I got you next slide don't sit down put your
hand down exactly stop asking dumb questions I've already thought about this yeah I will
that's a good future but every riddle instead of like a laser pointer they had like a
an extended major and I love that and I want one because then I can like no
I mean you can just buy a fly fishing rod it's nice and random like a little felt tip
anything else Anthony
uh for this one it's more just for like identifying like the what's it called like the core of the
philosophy so like it's so it stands out from the bottom stuff or the things next to it so like on
the other slides like this slide it's like the the colored box is the core philosophy I can just do
it for the other one the one that's on like the roadmap slide because that a lot of these slides
have so many animations it's not worth it for for that but yeah for like where is it the roadmap
slide wherever I don't know I talk about it outwardly so I don't think I need to and that's
also why it's like highlighted so it's kind of like uh well like it highlighted what I say it so
like I'll be like right we get to confusion and like this is where students can stop but we need
to push them through anything else Anthony I mean I think just answering it with like as technology
evolves we have to evolve our approaches also like if we don't yeah like we're gonna get left behind
I mean the the point here isn't like to show them more numbers it's just to be like we have to
modernize like we will fall behind current schools we're already behind current schools so like
if we want to stay behind I mean we can but you know nothing else nothing nothing else I'm stressed
what was that I still have my notes and I need to get rid of them because some of the notes I think
me because when I was writing them it's just kind of like barf on the page at times but like towards
the end there's no notes there because I just haven't gotten there but once I practice it a few
times I don't need my notes but it's hard to go back to the notes after I get stopped by a question
because I get I lose where I'm at so eventually I'll get rid of them or just boil it down into like
the main things that I want to talk about oh yeah yeah I see yeah this is my favorite part of the
oh yeah yeah I see yeah this is one of the longer note ones because it is like it's such a weird
study that like top hat but before it was top hat was like a physical clicker yeah
where is that how students learned how we assess them is it here yeah I'm debating what I want to
do here because it is like I feel like I spent a lot of time talking about the two types of exams
but I think it's important to like state like there are things that have been tried but I I'm
not saying we do these things but maybe something in between these things so I don't know if I need
both of them I think it's nice to have both of them because it shows like two very different
approaches to it I do need to fix that though so in setting one the traditional exams or the control
was just multiple choice so the treatment was setting one multiple choice with some creative
exercises in there setting two the traditional exams was multiple choice true false fill in the
blank and then same thing with the treatment multiple choice true false fill in the blank and
some creative exercises I'm pretty happy but yeah the transition from the last side to this
I think it's pretty good how we only have this few questions I mean like we didn't have a lot
like I was really just literally asking questions I knew the answer to just to go ahead and give you
that like you're going to have to look it has to be the top dot on here right it has to be
well there are middle dots well so because you're not getting less points with partial or like
you're not going negative with partial credit or what how am I trying to explain this so like
so like if you choose like answer choice b and the answer choice is a and answer choice b is
because like you flip like it was supposed to be products over reactants and you did reactants over
products you would get like 75 of the points so like this top dot sorry I did red on red that's
awful this top dot right here would be the score you would get with the dichotomous approach
or would it be the bottom dot because I guess that's the only confusing part here is
for every one dichotomous grade that you can get you can get multiple politimous grades
dichotomous is right or wrong right yes for 60% that's here yeah and then this range is like
20 40 60 I'm never going to be below that yes because this is like I got this all the way wrong
no points so it has to be above it has to be above so everything above yeah so like this would be like
you got a what is this a 60 something on the exam yeah so that's like the minimum score you
could get yeah but then it's and that's why I sell this as like it's helping students not
at the like boundary or not at the extremes it's helping those at the boundary because this like
red box in the middle shows like what we see the biggest deviation really it should be like
like where is it
but yeah it is a dumb graph but I think that makes because that's how I explained it first
and then I got in my own head about how do I explain this oh yeah it's it is a very bad graph
but it's all computer that's what I need to respond if someone asks me about
this technology it's all computer but okay because yeah this one I felt better I thought
I did need to group up the two things because having them separate it was I thought it was
confusing in my head it had to be confusing for other people to like
uh do it and then that just makes going over here I do feel like I will say appreciation
once I feel like you are saying this in an appropriate way where you know your audience
with how they're not going to a gore nuts and technology about students with a problem
so I do appreciate how like you are being very straightforward how like this is easy you can
see on the front the letter however you want and the ai is before you like you're taking off a
load from there she was actually okay I think that's good I gotta do well gotta kill it
Did you go to the clock yesterday? Nope I did not get back till 2 a.m. this morning.
So how did you get here? Well I had another interview at 11. Oh okay this morning? Yeah.
I think it went well they seemed to really like me but then they said they wanted the person to
start May 11th and I was like so just so you guys know my defense right now is tentatively
scheduled through like May 21st through the 23rd so like glad this interview went well but I also
don't want to like take up someone's spot or waste anyone's time so I'm telling you now
but they did seem to really like me and I felt bad having to like break that news to them like
well like if they could find someone to cover because it's just one section that they need
taught in the summer so it wasn't like a big workload it wasn't a full-time workload
but still I was like I mean I know one of the professors there anyways so it wasn't like a
hard connection to make but yeah I felt really bad I was like oh sorry sorry I know it said
summer but like so sometimes summer starts different times for different people so I thought
it would be well enough but okay there's no like big things that I need to change I'll work on
getting the script a little more like flowy so I don't need to look at my laptop as much
I try to keep it small I don't want to go like too much into like the ideas behind it because they
like here it's not to like show like this is exactly how we would grade this question but
like how we break up like some of the grading choices and like I don't really care what what
the cutoffs are here whatever it is it's just more like here's an idea and here's how we execute
this idea did you go to talk yesterday that was the other interview same so like I could see her
like abstract and bio but I don't think I'm allowed to be there well because like I wasn't
invited to the second talk but Ben said people were allowed to go to the second talk so I only
got the like lecture email but that also makes sense like the big talk of course they don't want
me going to because that would be wild behavior and I like I agree like I should not be there
are these the notes okay thank you okay nothing nothing else I mean Zach will tear me apart
tomorrow also so we'll see how that's going what time are we meeting with Luke tomorrow
is it today it's like is it four it's four pretty sure it's tomorrow okay
so I'll just check in when I'm meeting with Zach to to make sure
okay I mean what's that good too I mean it should be done by four but like if I'm a little late
I'm still right here just in another meeting what if you wanted to practice again
uh true uh do you guys if you have time do you want to see the other um what's it called
what's it called yeah the uh not much has changed but there's a few differences
Anthony can you see it I don't know I'll hold it there for a second well
I spent what was it 7 30 to 7 p.m. yes or Tuesday talking to people it was I had 11 meetings
I killed it I was so good at it I thought it was pretty funny how a new presentation
like I think I'm pretty good because I got like considering how my first award was about like
Scott likes course Scott like course structure I think I know what I'm doing he said something
like that something with for a recitation yeah I think I'm setting up pretty well to my first
award is the 401k award or something 401k you said something I did a 4k award yeah okay I
heard the words left in my ears but well I think like you have to leverage some of those things
right like well it was it was clever I'm appreciating I saw you do that I was kind
of like chucking myself like okay Kristen my flex like you have to leverage the little thing
since I'm not instructor record since I haven't coordinated it's like showing like I've done
other things that like with the things I'm suggesting I think I am well qualified to do these
I do think it was kind of out of place for you to put your awards at the bottom of your schedule
I'm like the second slide and I thought that was literally just like a source or something
or some like reference actually I'll read it I'm like wait a minute this actually says like
award like award one or two I mean the committee also has my cd so they can see all my awards like
yeah yeah it's more just like there if people are interested and those like aren't even all of them
it's just kind of like the teaching ones yeah I'm fancy even when I'm up there like I feel like
it's different than what I'm sitting here I'm a little bit better about sorry I was just making
sure something was aligned uh that is not like a different thickness is it just oh I think it's
just the angle on that okay yeah just where no okay I think it's just the angle the h is on an h3
I think I've just had a weird angle because like there it looks like the top one is thicker than
the middle one and then over here it looks like the middle one is thicker than the top one so I
think I'm just at a weird angle yeah but here it looks fine like looking on the screen
all right uh this is pretty much the same just changed up like very minor things
here's the title slide are you happy with the images anthony what's that
oh I see yeah okay okay um and then I go a little bit into about me it's going to be slightly
different than what I said during like the vision talk it'll be more like um I'm from UCF getting
my degree here I've taught a lot of classes and the way I teach corresponds to my teaching philosophy
so like not going into my teaching philosophy but really just like this is who I am and hopefully
when I'm teaching today you'll see like what I'm trying to do is these three things
uh and then I added in uh where we are in the semester so uh in gen chem this is the order of
topics I'm right here what they need to know beforehand and then pulling out some of the
things from these uh stuff so audience has an idea of what's going on if there's nothing listed
underneath it like bonding we need everything from bonding which is why I wasn't going to list
like 20 things I wasn't really going to list like the things underneath it I was just
going to be like the prior knowledge needed is this category specifically these things bonding
everything yeah I'm sure it's like the same I mean I use periodic trends here because that's what I
but like in the ebook it's called periodic properties title oh oh I'm looking at the left
all right yeah I prefer trends properties but I think there are some words that you can use
interchangeably and it'll be fine um and then to start off I'm going to give them this problem
why do we remove the first drops when making drinking alcohol and I'll give them some
background so a homemade alcohol mixture contains several types of liquid this apparatus is used to
separate the drinking alcohol but why don't we collect the first few drops I'll give them like
a minute to discuss it and be like think about it we'll come back to this idea um and that's a
copper still oh yeah just go into it nothing's really changed here oh that's the same uh not
much has changed here it just says thermal energy now uh and now I show n2 and how it's always the
same I have asked just changes at different thermal or the phase of matter changes at different
temperatures then going into what are these forces same thing here uh have a little crab
crab dude same thing here but now it moves in and then because it's near a temporary dipole it gets
a temporary dipole and that's how we get our ldfs and then this question I'll ask them I'll let
them talk about it and then once they're done talking about it I'll be like can you rank these
molecules and fun fact it's already ranked for them left to right right to left whatever way
but it's already ranked for them um and we'll move on uh all right well you answer that question but
what happens when they have the same molecular weight we'll talk about this added in the nice
models of it Ben sent me and then the spaghetti and gnocchi rather than the hamburger and meatball
or meatloaf people wanted it to be hot dogs yeah I the idea was just like large surface area
versus not as large surface area but yeah I mean I think this one makes sense
because spaghetti gets tangled easily because large surface area gnocchi does not get tangled
it's not based on how long it's going to be but like yeah um and then yeah going over these now
I have the surface area data uh I mean it's calculated and usually surface area data is
for ionic things so that's why there's nothing for the middle one and they're kind of close
anyways because these are just estimates but then I go back to this idea show the melting points show
that be like well we see some variation and like less of a trend for the melting points below
sc4 and that's because these are gases above it these are liquids and then talk about how the
isomers change and then really talk about like going from like the lit or like the cylindrical
to like the cylindrical and like kind of spherical one it's not a big change but then really changing
the surface area has a big drop in boiling point so like what we're going to care first and foremost
about is change in molecular weight then change in surface area I think this is the same I just
change the way the dipole looks I'll draw those on yeah I think this is all the same
yeah that's all the same I'm just pointing out like uh the yeah the strongest IMFs don't always
correlate with the strongest dipole dipoles and then we go to this example and talk about it I
mean I'll let them talk about both the examples but this is what I'll let them talk about and then
go back to this idea like now we see it again um I need to fix that was no for myself uh go here
talk about like what's going on with uh HF and then what's going on with HO I use the wrong
background for this so like my bond angles are wrong compared to the rest of the water
yeah yeah yeah so they're wrong um that was just to know what to fix that because like here it's
correct but the previous slide it's not but go here talk about uh what's happening with these
things um this one asks why hydrogen or why oxygen nitrogen or fluorine it's partly because
they're small um but really it's because of orbital overlap so like all of these are in the 2s so like
even though chlorine is more electronegative than nitrogen it's too big to have good overlap with
the 1s orbital of hydrogen so it doesn't go through hydrogen bonding um and then we go back
to this and now they have to rank the boiling points given they know about the three uh like
covalent or molecular IMFs uh and yeah that'll pop back up and then I'll go back to this and be like so
why do we remove the first drops and then be like well in this mixture we're gonna have a lot of
methanol and a lot of ethanol what's getting distilled out first or what's getting heated out
first what's uh they've already have answered this question essentially and then same thing here
takeaway takeaway and then now it like bolts it as I go through it these are the things that we've
covered I like the example you added to them it might have stolen that from Zach yeah I figure
it's nice because throughout the thing they'll answer the question then we'll come back and
I'll be like well the types of liquids in here are this and this and the how we separate it is
through boiling point started off have you all made mood chime before actually the very first
experiment I ever did in the lab like even before taking classes was doing alcohol because I started
my summer research before I was on chemistry class but yeah uh any comments anthony concerns
questions you hate it this one I'm not too worried about lectures are
and he has his own little a little citation says that Katona Anthony says that is it that is it
I am I am feeling away not a great way but away it's fine everything's fine I mean Anthony still
has a bum knee I don't think we'd enjoy that I feel like that would be a very very bad time
for both of us wait is that why you're not here I don't know why you weren't here but I just
realize now so it mostly yeah nothing no criticisms nothing to be like fuck Christian you're not going
to get this job bad I mean if it's the truth yeah I still have time to fix things
no okay well I guess that's it then I guess I guess I will go try to find someone who went to
the lecture tomorrow don't tell me to start moving I'll do what I want um yeah because I'll go find
someone who went and be like how was it pro for information
Leo Leo all right thank you Anthony see you later I think um Ben said he'll let us know when he's
ready um so sometime after 3 30 is my guess and then uh I think anti-fragile because that's what's
open okay all right goodbye thank you for your time